hi i'm kevin from clay entertainment the
creators of don't starve hello I'm Robin
are not the creator of sound cell I'm
249 from similar the creators of device
sake hi I'm eat i hearing from hunting
the creators of mushroom of it I'm learn
for now and I'm Audrey benavides I'm
Brian Edelman and I Bobby mahjong and we
have tamed parallax turkey I hi I'm
Peter one of the creators of perfect
woman were nominated for the 2014 I GF
moooo 4ward watch live on gamespot on
March the 19th to see if device 6 wins
watch it live on games bar on March 19th
to see a air-elec wins plus right now go
and vote for sound self for the audience
choice award before the voting closes on
march first go vote for mushroom 11 is
your favorite game for the audience
award go vote for perfect woman as your
favorite game for the audience award go
vote for Dominique moms this is your
favorite game go to device 6 as your
favorite game for the audience award go
vote for don't starve as your favorite
game for the audience award before
voting closes on march first why this is
the peril a claw go I'm talking that is
you need to look out for when you vote
for parallax for the audience award do
that before march first when devote ends